number 20 the new york giants your
boyhood favorite team the giants how can
you disrespect the giants have you not
seen
have you not seen what they are doing to
put pieces around daniel jones to allow
him to become the next phil sims the
next eli manning of that proud franchise
peter
well
let me just say this mike
this proud franchise now this is the
10-year anniversary of when they last
won a playoff game and that was a big
playoff game they beat the patriots
you know at the end of that uh
at the end of the 2011 season obviously
but
you know i just want to see it first
mike i i and it isn't that i doubt them
but the jury's still out on daniel jones
he has played okay but not great and
he's had some really good moments
but
he's had some ugly moments as well
so let's see i don't really know what to
think of daniel jones now offensively
they are going to be a lot better
they're going to be a lot better in the
running game with saquon barkley coming
back and they're going to be a lot
better at wide receiver with cadarius
tony uh obviously and kenny gallaudet
the one guy on this team that i think is
being forgotten right now
is when you bring kyle rudolph onto your
team and everybody ah you know it's just
insurance for evan ingram
hey look
joe judge saw what happened in new
england
in when they went to two tight end sets
and no one is going to say that kyle
rudolph has the athleticism of either
rob gronkowski or the late aaron
hernandez but he is a very good nfl
tight end and i think he's got one year
or maybe two
left
to really impact a game
so i like him almost as well as i like
let's say cadarius tony to help this
quarterback especially in the
intermediate part of the field having
said all that
you know i just would like to see them
play well and consistently on offense
and look
we're going to see how well they'll do
on defense
but i think they lost a huge piece
with dalvin tomlinson going to the
vikings that's one of the big gets in
free agency that nobody's talking about
very much
but i just want to see the giants do it
the last four years we haven't seen it
one of
the challenges of doing power rankings
when everyone is zero and zero and will
remain zero and zero for several more
months
somebody's got to be 20. somebody's got
to be 28 somebody's got to be 31. and at
a time when fan bases have been soaking
up any and all hope they can find
from the end of the season until post
draft they don't want to hear that it's
going to fail even though
someone is going to be 20. someone is
going to be 28 someone is going to be 31
that's just how it works and as to the
giants i firmly believe when you look at
kenny galladay and all the money they
spent on him first round pick on
cadarius tony the after they missed out
on devonta smith when they got
leapfrogged by the eagles kyle rudolph
the all these pieces it's a no excuses
season for daniel jones he's either
going to make a jump and we're going to
be gushing about him the way we gushed
about josh allen last year or
it's going to be someone else next year
as the quarterback in the new york
giants this is the pressure cooker that
daniel jones is being placed into no
excuses get it done this year or next
year you're not going to be on the team
see the interesting part of the giants
is
just think about this year versus next
year and you're right mike i think the
entire uh
you know ethos
of picking quarterbacks now has changed
and changed rather dramatically daniel
jones going into his third year and this
is his prove it year this is it okay
tuatanga valor going into his second
year i'm not saying it's his proven year
but it might be
and this never used to be this way
quarterbacks used to get a lot more
string to be able to prove themselves
but and i'm just saying this is a big
but because i don't think this is going
to happen but i think it might happen
and that is the new york giants
if they're lousy this year will have a
high draft pick and the new york giants
will also have chicago's first round
pick this year now who knows chicago
might be picking around 20 again you
never know but suppose that the giants
have the sixth pick and they got the
20th pick in reserve and they like one
of the young quarterbacks
i
chuckle
when everybody said yeah the quarterback
crop next year is lousy
how in the world do you have any idea
what the quarterback crop is next year
did anybody think that one year ago that
zach wilson was going to be the second
pick in the draft nobody heard of zach
wilson a year ago and so and i don't
know if zach wilson is going to make it
or not but don't tell me that there
aren't going to be good quarterbacks in
the draft next year it's a bunch of
malarkey
aunt peter
even if we get to the end of the 2021
college season and there isn't a great
crop and i agree with you it's too early
to know
you got ammunition that you could use to
trade for one of these veterans that is
disgruntled that may want to play in new
york remember it was two years ago when
russell wilson was posturing for his
latest contract the giants new york city
that was a destination that was
mentioned for russell wilson so that
could come back after this season and
they've got those two first round picks
this year 2022 in the next draft that
they could dangle in order to make that
happen
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports